did Ryan Reynolds reveal the gender of  baby number two guilty as charged  Blake Lively and Ryan welcomed their  second child in September a source  confirmed two et well the Deadpool star  may have just spilled the beans on the  pair's newborn on Thursday when he  tweeted quote the mobile above my  daughter's crib is just a whole bunch of  new viryx so she remembers how lucky she  is Brian and Blake already shared  daughter James who turns 2 in December  and we're hoping the tiny tot has  outgrown her crib and has her first  big-girl bed by now the famously private  couple have yet to formally announce the  gender of their recent bundle of joy but  a couple of users responded to the  actors tweet writing what we were  thinking quote so it's a girl and so you  have two girls Ryan has yet to tweet  back but we think he'll have an amazing  comeback I will come up with something  spectacular